- Each year at Commencement,
our university recognizes
an exceptional group
of individuals with Honorary Degrees.
These degrees are the most
significant distinction
conferred by the Yale Corporation,
the university's Board of Trustees,
to signal pioneering
achievement in a field
or conspicuous and exemplary contribution
to the common good.
Though we cannot adorn
this year's Honorary Degree recipients
in their academic hoods,
or applaud their
accomplishments as they stand
on the Commencement stage,
we gather from our computers, phones,
and devices around the
world to recognize the ways
in which they have expanded our knowledge
and gifted us with their art,
song, scholarship, and innovation.
Today, we honor nine individuals
who serve as examples
to our graduates and members
of the Yale community.
They encourage us to aspire to excellence
and to value those
elements of human character
that they embody;
creativity, curiosity,
discipline, integrity,
and a passion for public service.
Their association with the Class of 2020
also honors the students
who graduate today.
Collectively they represent
the aspirations of Yale
as an institution.
It is now my distinct pleasure
to announce the 2020
honorary degree recipients
and to confer their degrees.
For the degree of Doctor of Laws,
Jerome Alan Cohen, Legal Scholar.
Pioneering scholar of Chinese law,
you have taught and
mentored countless others
in a field you helped
establish in this country.
A courageous voice
for those whose voices have been silenced,
you defend human rights around the globe.
Bold trail blazer and advocate,
for using your many talents
to create a more just world,
we are proud to present you
with your third Yale degree,
Doctor of Laws.
For the degree of Doctor of Music,
Herbie Hancock, Musician and Composer.
Chameleon of modern jazz,
you have shown us new possibilities
and encouraged us to
imagine a better world.
By experimenting with science and sound,
you let your talent take you, and us,
to new places,
breaking down barriers between genres
and creating chords of
peace that connect humanity.
Wonderful wizard and musical icon,
Yale is delighted to confer on you this
Doctor of Music degree.
For the degree of Doctor
of Humane Letters,
Christiana Figueres, Public Servant.
Your diplomacy has brought
people and nations together
to address one of the
most important issues
of our time, climate change.
Building bridges instead of borders,
you've led countries to action,
helping forge international
accords to ensure the health
and survival of future
generations on this planet.
Global citizen, skilled leader,
Yale is honored
to award you this Doctor
of Humane Letters degree.
For the degree of Doctor of
Engineering and Technology,
Michael I. Jordan, Computer Scientist.
Facing an uncertain and complex world,
you harness the power of
human and machine learning
to solve daunting problems.
By bridging disciplines and
following your curiosity,
you have made possible what
was once only imagined.
Explorer of new domains,
champion of big ideas,
in recognition of the
doors you have opened
and the networks you have built,
we proudly bestow on you
this Doctor of Engineering
and Technology degree.
For the degree of Doctor of Fine Arts,
Ming Cho Lee, Theatrical Set Designer.
You have set the world on stage
and your influence circles the globe.
Your classroom is legendary.
With insight and humility,
you inspired thousands of Yale
students to create new vistas
of art and meaning.
Generous teacher, visionary artist,
for helping us see, feel, and
understand the great drama
of human life anew,
we are delighted to confer on you
this Doctor of Fine Arts degree.
For the degree Doctor of Science,
Svante Pääbo, Evolutionary Geneticist.
From bone fragments
thousands of years old,
you show us what has endured
and what has been lost from ancient times
to the present day.
Applying the latest science
to age old questions,
you have revealed secrets
about the prehistoric world,
discovered previously unknown species,
and invented a new field of study.
Passionate scientist,
for opening a window onto
our ancestors and ourselves,
Yale is privileged to confer on you
this Doctor of Science degree.
For the degree of Doctor of Music,
Renée Fleming, Soprano.
You have shared your extraordinary voice
on the world's greatest stages,
thrilling audiences with
you repertoire and range.
Transcending styles and traditions,
you champion the importance
of music for our health,
minds, and communities.
Soaring soprano, lyrical
ambassador of the arts,
for helping us hear all the
octaves of life more clearly,
we are honored to present you
with this Doctor of Music degree.
For the degree of Doctor
of Medical Sciences,
Jim Allison, Immunologist.
Your discoveries have
transformed the science
of cancer treatment,
opening up new frontiers in medicine.
By unleashing the power of T-cells,
you enlisted the body's own immune system
to combat this terrible disease,
and your research has restored
health and hope to patients.
Laureate and lifeline,
in honor of the futures
you have made possible,
we gratefully bestow on you
this Doctor of Medical Sciences degree.
And for the degree of Doctor of Letters,
Paula Vogel, Playwright and Educator.
While waltzing or
driving, dying or loving,
your characters connect with audiences
and bring urgent issues
out of the shadows.
A devoted teacher,
you foster the future of theater,
helping young playwrights
find their voices
and refine their craft.
In appreciation for your brave artistry
and spirited mentorship,
Yale is proud to award you
this Doctor of Letters degree.
I send my warm
congratulations to all of you.
The entire university joins me
in applauding your accomplishments.
Welcome, to the Class of 2020.